how many book clubs are you a part of uh
just one just one yeah how long have you
been a part of it
I think it started in
2016. I think is when it started so what
is that seven years six years or
something like that now oh it's the same
book club that you found wow okay yeah
what are the rules for joining a book
club uh mine or in general okay both
yeah uh I don't know about in general I
don't know what the hell they're you
know they're going on over there but for
us it's like uh it has to be I mean you
have to show an interest in reading for
one and you have to read the book like
you know I know there's a lot of book
clubs that they don't read the book
which I find crazy like yeah it's a
thing like where people would just be
like they're not reading the book and
then the book clubs kind of just
disappear right because it's not
sustainable if you don't read the book
uh and usually it's like you have to
amongst us you know it's like you're
gonna uh you have to be recommended
right like someone has to know you you
know from the book club and kind of like
bring you in because uh we just don't
I mean you have to be vetted like I need
to know you're going to read the book
like I need you know that's what it's
really about it's like where you know
who we're dealing with and being like oh
is this person like does he read do they
read you know does she read like does
she actually read the book and want to
engage about it because there's a lot of
people who uh they they don't actually
read the book it's it's crazy I know it
sounds wild like why would you join a
book club and not read the book but
there are a lot of people who do that
you know it's like they don't dates yeah
you know maybe they have ulterior
motives where it's like you know maybe
they just want friends and stuff which
is like fine you know but read the book
too like you know
okay so they have to know that you know
hey is he cool or yeah yeah okay you can
come in yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah as you
read the book
how many people work best as a book club
like is there a point where it gets to
be too many is there a point where it's
too little
um I mean I can only assume if you only
have two members including yourself it's
not really a book club right like so it
has to be more than that you know uh but
uh for us I mean we have quite a few
members uh because we have different
chapters in different states So like
um for our West Coast chapter we have
about how many members do we have in
this it's like five or six including me
um and then we have a Southeast chapter
there's about 10 members there and then
we have an East Coast chapter and
there's about like four
four members there
is this virtual or you're actually
meeting in person with so many people so
each chapter meets like we don't meet
with the other groups you know the other
chapters we meet amongst ourselves in
person but like you know usually about
once a year or once every two years like
well like I'll read the same book and
then hop on a giant zoom and like all be
discussing it and stuff like that
um and before the pandemic we did it two
years in a row where all the chapters
would read this we'd pick a country we'd
all find a book and vote on it from that
country and we'd read it and then we'd
all fly to that country for a long
weekend and then we would like discuss
it oh wow that's pretty cool yeah
normally are they held at a coffee shop
or someone's home uh for mine the weed
like uh we usually someone hosts and
then we cook like dinner and have wine I
don't drink but everyone else has wine
uh and like yes and just becomes like a
an evening oh an evening okay so that
that would help with the vetting too
because they're letting in people that
they don't yeah
why is it important for you to be in a
book club
I don't know I just like it like you
know it's like you
you know you create a bond with people
and like sometimes when you read a book
you kind of want to talk to somebody
about it hear everybody's thoughts and
like you know argue you know on the
merits of it and it helps you see new
light on it stuff you might have missed
and like it it can open a book up quite
a bit you know when you're talking to it
with a bunch of other people and
um strengthens friendships obviously you
know I get to eat a good meal and like I
think it's healthy to be around people
and talk to them and have those kind of
things so I think it serves a lot
it's hard to meet people in LA and and
it's not based on something maybe
superficial like going to a club where
you know people ask you you know what do
you do you know this is just based on an
author's work so yeah yeah that's nice
yeah it's fun do you read I do I've read
a lot of stuff uh in the past it's
harder to do it with film courage but
yeah during the pandemic I read a lot of
stuff of with the Libby app yeah and I
do miss reading and I do like books over
um you know but uh it's it's been
tougher to even see movies yeah yeah but
um yeah I do I do miss it
and I read um a book about a woman who
worked at a publishing
um company in New York City and Salinger
was one of their clients and they were
all told like oh when you get Salinger
on the phone to tell so and so and you
know and and yeah it turned out he was
really nice yeah so he wasn't as as mean
as as this this like crazy guy that was
that was you know made out to be and it
was her life and you know she was
you know teenage or a young woman in the
90s and I just yeah I miss I miss
reading and I like you know Alice Monroe
um you know Margaret Atwood oh yeah yeah
people whose books get banned yeah yeah
Judy Bloom but anyway
um bring it back keep reading yeah keep
reading it's time do you get to finish
the book oh like in this book club it's
about
depending on what's going on but it's
probably anywhere around four to like
six or seven weeks
oh okay yeah so we're meeting about once
a month uh once a month and a half and
stuff like that every once in a while
we'll run into like a two-month thing
because you know whether it's Christmas
holiday season or whatever and we're
like okay well it's going to take a
little bit longer to kind of get through
these things and yeah but for the most
part on average it's probably about once
every four or six weeks and you all
bring a copy of the book with you to the
club or no depends on how cool the book
is you know it's like if you're like me
I pride myself in the hardcovers that I
buy you know so I'll bring it and I'll
show it off and then uh one of the
members will be like well I got a better
one and like and slide it you know it's
like I see it in there so well you know
we'll do that
what book should be required reading in
a book club
oh
I don't know if there should like be
I don't know if there should be required
reading I think I think there should be
required like
discussion you know like because that's
what the point of uh or one of the
points of like a book club is you know
it's like is the the discussion and the
camaraderie amongst the the members you
know and and a safe space for you guys
to kind of voice your your your
criticisms and your feelings and on the
book and then the literature you know
but I don't think any you know I don't
think there should be a like oh you know
every book club needs to read this I
think it's a matter of the interest of
the the members you know what they're
what they're interested in Reading you
know
can you take us through sort of a
virtual experience of what it would be
like to be at this book club like if if
you know someone's hosting it are you
showing up with your own potluck you're
bringing like you know the side dish and
a book yeah yeah so you know I'll just
take you through like a an even when I'm
hosting you know what I do is like you
know I'll cook a whole meal you know so
for let's see for this one you know like
for instance I did a
um
what's a meal I did for everyone I did
like I did a lemon pepper chicken honey
lemon pepper chicken with you know mixed
vegetables and this recipe that they
call a Brazilian rice it's really just
like rice with onions and garlic and
cilantro kind of you know but how it's
prepared is a little bit different than
people I don't know if this is like it
might actually not be brazilianized but
that's what the title of the recipe said
but you know those are the ingredients
and then we'll bring you know and then
there'll be a dessert and I did a creme
brulee for for the dessert and so like
what will happen is it's like you know
the people start to show up there'll be
some small talk because we haven't seen
each other in a month and you know what
we've been up to
um you know then I'll unveil the meal
everyone will get their meal they'll
pour the either the wine or the uh
whatever drinks that we're having and
we'll sit around the table and you know
we'll jump it off and I'll be like well
so how did you feel about 100 Years of
Solitude and so we'll start uh to start
discussing it and um uh while we're
having a great feast so similar to how
John Favreau did oh yeah yeah you're
doing dinner in a book yeah yeah okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah right yeah nice
one yeah Saturday or Sunday evening most
the time so has there any been any
heated arguments well the things where
people keep it pretty respectful yeah no
there's never really been any uh that's
again why the vetting process you know
we're always like you know who's who's
coming up in here eating us like so nah
we all are very uh civil about it you
know there are there's exchanges not
like you say but there's like
differences in opinions like you know
when there's like a polarizing book on
people who are just like you know
whether they don't like it or not you
know but those always make the best
discussions you know it's just like when
a book is very polarizing so for
whatever reason 100 Years of Solitude
was a pretty polarizing book uh I loved
it some other people there like you know
didn't really like it for whatever
reasons but uh that was our that was our
best discussion you know was talking
about that book
what was the first book that defined
Your Love of Storytelling
um
okay so I don't know the first book that
I like that I picked up
uh
I don't know I can't say that there was
a book that like made me kind of be that
like I just kind of started picking up
reading like you know I remember there's
a book called Wizard's First Rule that I
picked up in like when I was really
young and I really liked it so I was
just kind of reading that series which
brought me to Harry Potter and then I
read you know some of that series and uh
then I uh forgot there's oh A Series of
Unfortunate Events like I was reading
that and then I started reading some of
the you know classic Western Literature
Like Frankenstein and The Divine Comedy
and um The Count of Monte Cristo and
stuff like that and like it just really
started like it was just kind of a
process I was like opening up
storytelling I should say he you know
that really started opening it up as a
as a craft to me and you know also as
something to experience but yeah I can't
say that there was like
one book that made me kind of be like oh
my God like it was just kind of like
slowly building to a point where I was
just like I started recognizing craft
you know as I was reading it
you know I can definitely say like when
I read Elmer Leonard I read all his
books
and like that kind of get you know
opened up craft a little bit to me you
know because he has a certain Swagger
you know with his writing and his
dialogue and stuff like that and so
because of that it showed me something
you know and even how he describes a
character or how he doesn't describe a
character like uh that you know opened
up to me because when you just read
someone's like all their work you're
gonna start picking up on their their
their style you know
what tips do you have for others if
they'd like to find a book club
um
yeah I think like
yeah you want I don't want to say
like-minded but you do want like-minded
people who like in the sense of they all
like to read you know you don't really
want to be involved in a book club of
people who don't actually like to read
because they're not going to read you
know and then people to create a space
where you feel comfortable talking about
the book you know so you can express
your thoughts and engage with someone
you know because like that's another
muscle to exercise is you know
expressing your thoughts on something
that you that you read and what you
liked and what you disliked and what you
were ambivalent about you know it's just
like and then being comfortable to do
that these are all different things you
know that you you need to be able to do
so I would say just having a space where
the people involved are allowing for
that you know you don't want someone
who's just going to be like I don't care
about your opinion like you know it's
just like you want to space it's a very
welcoming space for that kind of stuff
and are these mostly fiction books or
their Memoir
um yeah I think like Memoirs like so
we're mostly like fiction narrative you
know is what the backbone is but we're
willing to do like uh Memoir you know or
historical fiction you know those can be
a part of it but
you know it's working off the backbone
of like you know it's fictitious
narrative like fiction you know
uh what about political books is that
something that in the past few years
maybe have been come less popular or or
is is that not off the table nothing's
nothing's off the table uh we've never
really done a political book oh no yeah
it just is it just never happens because
we're always kind of like first we're
like you know first we were chasing
literary periods where it's like oh
Victorian romantic modern and you know
stuff like that and then then we were
just like okay well like genres you know
fantasy horror you know uh sci-fi like
we were kind of just like doing that so
there's never really been a moment where
like a political book even like crossed
our minds because we were just jumping
all these other things have you ever
participated in a Movie Club
um
no I've been approached but I've never
really they hand you a car yeah just
like are you gonna be you know but I
don't know it's weird like so
I think it's part of the reason why some
people don't join book clubs too because
it's just like the commitment of it they
don't like the the idea like going into
the future right they're just like what
forever right you know it's like you
think about that and I feel like with
movie clubs like that kind of
uh and oh oh oh oh and also you don't
want it to feel like homework this is
going back to what else you asked you
know so you don't want
my whole goal with the book club as well
is like I don't want it to feel like
homework because the second something
feels like homework or a task you're not
going to want to do it
you you know what I mean so it's like
for for a book club I think that's I
think that's crucial you don't ever want
this to feel like homework so try
whatever you can use in your power to
make it not feel like homework you know
utilize that
um but I think for a movie clip that is
the thing that happened to me it's like
everyone who approaches me it always
feels like it's going to be homework
that I have to watch this movie instead
of something where I'm like I'm just
seeking out like you know a movie that
you know I found or someone recommended
to me you know it's like even though
it's like technically the same thing
it's just like whenever it's like Movie
Club then it feels like homework all
right so
well with the book club they don't
require notes correct you're just going
and talking about over dinner yeah yeah
there's no like study guide or anything
like that you you know it's like it's
just we're just having a casual
conversation